- Hi!
- [Kelly] You probably--
- I match your pink.
- I know, you match the set. You do.
But oh my God, you probably,
I always know girls with
curly hair naturally
are always like, I wish it were straight.
Your hair is so wonderful.
- Thanks.
- It's like a fricking hair commercial.
You just walked out here.
- That's so nice.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- I straightened it,
I chemically straightened it
for years and then I gave up.
- Oh my God, I'm so jealous.
It's so beautiful.
- I also had a daughter
and I was like, you know,
I should just start wearing
my hair the way it is.
Why should I tell her that
she should make her hair
look anything other than how
it grows out of her head?
- [Kelly] Absolutely, yeah.
- So I was like, you know what?
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- That's for her.
- And you possibly found
that becoming a mother,
there is less time to straighten it.
- Wait. Time? There's time?
- [Kelly] It's gone. Everything's gone.
- No! This is my first
time I'm actually ever,
I've ever been away from her.
- Oh no, are you doing okay?
- I'm great.
- [Kelly] I remember I freaked out.
But you're--
- I'm great.
- No, there's also that half of you.
No, that half of you,
that's just like, oh my God,
this is what it's like
to just pee on my own.
Like, you know, there's just,
there's things you do that
you forgot where yours
- Peeing is amazing.
- Yes! Without someone at the door--
- Also I'm used to peeing
while wearing the Babybjorn.
- [Kelly] Yep.
- And if you've ever tried
to get under the Bjorn
to unbutton the top one,
you can get it down and then
you do whatever you have to do.
- Yeah.
- Finish, and then getting up
you have to get the jeans
under the Bjorn again.
- Yeah. Which is more difficult.
- It's a whole situation.
- Than the off, yes.
- Of course I miss her but I'm
also not covered in yogurt.
So there's that.